[Music]
it's time for ETS late-night roundup
you're a quick look at all the best TV
scoop after dark you could have any
superpower what would it be oh I'd like
to have like this supercool alien
high-tech ring and it's green and it has
a lantern on it that's a really dumb
superpower Ryan Reynolds brought the
laughs on Tuesdays Late Show poking fun
at his superhero past in Canadian roots
during the big questions with even
bigger stars bits where do you think we
go when we die
Canadian heaven is real an American
heaven is inside the body of Toby Keith
Reese Witherspoon opened up to Conan
O'Brien about working with Oprah on a
wrinkle in time somebody did the voice
feel like hello and then she also just
loves to like bring everybody muffins
she has muffins flown in from Napa and
she gets them to the entire crew the
mother of three also got candid about
her parenting style I guess I'm kind of
strict about stuff but I just kind of
communicate with them in funny ways like
I who's through my daughter said the
other day she's like it's like we look
like dad but we got our weirdness from
you there's nothing weird about Joe
Manganiello impressions they're
straight-up hilarious and spot-on
the Magic Mike actor showed off his
skills on Tuesdays tonight's show hi-ho
Kermit the Frog here Arnold
Schwarzenegger the traps and the
Cannonball belts and the biceps and the
triceps
[Music]